- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is be great!
Over to you, Noel Gallagher.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- They can't be the
greatest band in the world,
playing in a pub somewhere tonight
that nobody's heard of, with the Internet.
If you're great, you're going to make it.
- Yep.
- That's just a fact.
There can't be any, "Well,
we didn't make it, because
"we're working class."
Or something, do you know what I mean?
It's like if you're writing
the best songs in the world,
you're going to make it.
The end.
When Oasis came along, we
didn't have the Internet.
If we would've had the Internet,
we'd have been bigger than the universe.
You know what I mean?
We could've reached everybody.
- Yeah.
- But we did it, we were
forced to do it the hard way.
These new bands have all the advantage of
these devices that can get
you to everybody in the world
at the click of a button.
And all they've got to come up with is,
oh, right, yeah, the difficult
bit is the (bleeping) songs.
- It's never been easier
to win if you're talented.
There's nobody holding you back.
There's nobody saying that
you can't have success.
And never has it been easier to win,
regardless of where you come from,
regardless of how much money you have,
or who your parents are, or
what country you're from,
or who your friends are.
It's never been easier to win.
It's never been more about meritocracy,
about earning it.
And so if you're not achieving the success
that you think you deserve to have,
it's nobody else's fault.
Stop making excuses.
Stop blaming other people.
Take some accountability.
It's you.
You are where you are because of you.
You are where you are because
you're not adding enough value
to other people's lives.
And you can.
But it only starts to happen
when you accept the responsibility,
because as long as it's
somebody else's fault,
as long as your school's
fault, or your parent's fault,
or the President's fault,
or somebody else's fault,
then you're never going
to take the action,
'cause you have the easy way out.
'Cause you're great, you're amazing,
and it's this person's fault.
It's my ex-husband's fault,
it's my business partner's
fault, it's my family's fault.
It's always somebody else's fault.
And that's going to be the
story for the rest of your life.
And you're never going to reach
the potential you can have
because you don't want to,
'cause you want to stay
stuck where you are.
You want to just keep
blaming other people,
and never actually take
those big steps forward.
You deserve every bit of
success that you have,
both in a good way and a bad way.
And I like to say this
on my YouTube channel.
People say that I've had a lot of success
with the YouTube channel
and 600,000 subscribers,
and all that.
So, on the one hand, I deserve
those 600,000 subscribers,
because I've been putting
out a lot of work,
a lot of hustle, a lot of energy,
a lot of love, a lot of
heart, blood, sweat, tears
goes into making these
videos for you every day.
So I deserve to have 600,000 subscribers.
A lot of people leave comments saying,
"Man, your videos are so good.
"You deserve to have six
million subscribers."
I don't deserve six million
subscribers, not yet.
My stuff isn't good enough, yet.
I'm not good enough, yet.
Our process isn't good enough, yet.
The research isn't good enough, yet.
The editing isn't good enough, yet.
It's not good enough, yet.
Like, you guys don't
watch every single video
that I make on the channel
and then instantly share
it with your friends.
Every video we make doesn't go viral,
because it's not good enough.
Some of them take off and
blow up and others don't.
I didn't provide enough value to you guys.
You don't want to share it.
And that's not on you.
It's not like, "My audience
sucks and they don't share it,
"I'm so good, and they're not sharing it.
"It's on them, it's on my audience,
"'cause they're not sharing my stuff."
or "It's the YouTube algorithm.
"That stupid YouTube
algorithm is destroying me."
Right?
As long as there's some other reason,
then I'm not going to work harder
to get better.
So I don't deserve to have
six million subscribers.
I'm not down on myself.
I deserve to have the
600K, I'm happy with that.
I did a lot of work to get here.
I'm not saying that I suck.
I don't suck.
I'm good.
But I'm not six million good.
I need to get there, I want to get better.
I'm hungry to get there.
I want to add more value to you guys.
I look up to other speakers
who've had tons of success,
like Les Baron and Tony Robbins.
And I want to learn from
there to make myself better.
And so you deserve to be where you are.
If you produce good stuff in
this era, it will take off.
It's so easy to share.
There are no gatekeepers,
there are no limits anymore.
There's nobody that you
need to get in touch with
and that person's going
to make you a star.
You can make yourself a star now.
The problem is, you're
not good enough, yet.
And that's a hard pill to swallow.
But if you do swallow
it, and you accept it,
then it forces you to get better.
And the good thing is you
realize that you have the tools
to go out and get better.
You can change the course of your life
because you don't rely on gatekeepers,
or anybody else making you a star,
you can make it happen for your yourself
if you want to put in the
work to getting better.
There is nobody holding you
back from achieving success,
but yourself.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what's the reason you're telling yourself
you're not more successful?
I'm curious.
Are you blaming somebody else?
Or have you blamed
somebody or something else
in the past?
I'm curious.
Leave it down in the comments below.
We'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tommy Gonzalez.
Tommy, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
Hey, Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it.
I'm going to share some extra bonus clip
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- I don't understand the industry.
I don't understand where music is headed.
I don't really understand technology.
I just know that when you walk into a club
and you see a band that blows you away,
you are going to follow that band.
You're going to either buy their CD,
or you're going to find them online,
or you're going to see them the next time
they come to play.
You don't have to stand in line
at the song contest on TV
to become a (bleeping) popular musician.
Product placement and labels,
and A&R people, and all
that bull (bleeping)
it doesn't (bleeping) matter.
I swear to God.
It doesn't matter.
And if you back that up with the idea
that just playing those great songs
in your great live band
is enough reward for you,
then you're (bleeping) set.
But you've got to be badass.
You just have to be really good.
It's the other things that make up
for you musical inability.
I mean, as a drummer, I never felt like
I'm going to be on the cover
of Modern Drummer Magazine,
because I'm the best (bleeping)
drummer in the world.
I just knew that if you put me on stage
without a (bleeping) PA or floor monitors
in a small club, that I
would beat the (bleeping)
out of my drum so much that people go,
"Goddamn, did you see
that (bleeping) drummer?
"Whoa!"